bienvenue à la facture voici l'histoire
de deux femmes qui vivent l'enfer de la
covid longue n'allez surtout pas leur
dire ça va bien aller avec le petit
arc-en-ciel parce que ce qu'elle
voudrait entendre c'est on va vous aider
première vue les personnes atteintes de
covidence peuvent avoir l'air normal il
faut y regarder de plus près pour
constater le mal qui les ronge
essoufflement fatigue perte de mémoire
douleur articulaires
Nancy perron âgé de 54 ans ne peut même
pas prendre son petit-fils dans ses bras
j'ai mal puis j'ai des vertiges j'ai
peur de l'échapper
lorsqu'on lui parle il est évident
qu'elle est affligée d'un brouillard
cérébral
on dirait que
mon cerveau il vit
c'est ça le brouillard cérébral
[Musique]
autrefois elle était un véritable bouton
de train
mais cette maladie reconnue par l'OMS la
complètement transformé
elle s'épuise au moins très fort selon
Statistique Canada la Corée de longue a
affecté environ 1,4 millions de
Canadiens près de 5% de la population et
la maladie touche davantage les femmes
que les hommes
l'imagination vous avez plus
l'imagination pour faire ça non elle
n'arrive plus à créer comme avant et à
dû quitter son emploi dans un garage
selon son médecin de famille et son
ergothérapeute elle est incapable de
travailler
je suis invalide
mais
j'ai eu la réponse de la Régie des reins
et j'ai été refusée
la Régie des rentes qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui retraite Québec refuse de la
déclarer invalide parce qu'on estime que
sa condition médicale n'est pas
suffisamment grave pour l'empêcher
d'exercer un emploi à temps plein est-ce
que vous pouvez travailler non je ne
peux pas travailler je me considère
comme un homme bi
n’insupéron a bénéficié de l'assurance
emploi pendant 15 semaines puis plus
rien elle n'a pas droit à l'aide sociale
et n'a pas d'assurance salaire au
travail privé de revenus elle crée de
tout perdre vous êtes obligé de demander
de l'aide de vos filles Oui au niveau de
l'argent c'est gênant
a été terrassé par la covid en juillet
2020 et ne s'en est jamais remise elle a
39 ans et a maintenant recourt un
fauteuil roulant retraite Québec lui a
refusé une rente d'invalidité d'environ
800$ par mois
mon médecin de famille lui avait dit
diagnostiqué la covid de Londres et mon
internet lui il y a diagnostiquer
l'encéphale au milieu
[Musique]
de longue perdure jusqu'à 50% des
personnes atteintes pourraient souffrir
de l'encéphalomyélite mialgique qu'on
appelle aussi le syndrome de fatigue
chronique avant la covid Valérie Mary
était le pilier sa famille moi j'étais
venu hyperactif j'avais toujours mis le
projet je faisais du jardinage pendant
des heures j'allais faire du vélo avec
les enfants tout ça ça me manque
ça manque beaucoup
aujourd'hui le moindre bruit la lumière
et le mouvement lui cause des malaises
comme nous l'avons constaté lors du
tournage
mon quotidien est par celui de combat
devoir faire le choix entre ok
aujourd'hui je prends une douche ou
aujourd'hui je vais essayer de plier du
linge
impossible pour elle de travailler mes
retraites Québec lui a écrit nous ne
pouvons pas vous déclarer invalide car
votre condition médicale fait toujours
l'objet de traitement actif par
conséquent nous ne pouvons pas statuer
sur la gravité ni sur la permanence de
votre condition médicale dans ma
condition c'est impossible que j'envoie
plus spécialiste madame
[Musique]
le professeur Simon des caries vient
d'être nommé qu'aux directeur
scientifique du Réseau de Recherche en
canadien sur la codée de longue pour lui
cette réponse de retraite Québec est un
non sens la question c'est qu'est-ce
qu'on fait pour la supporter
financièrement pendant qu'on explore les
options thérapeutiques et là et la
faille du système on est des centaines
de chercheurs de haut niveau j'ai besoin
de temps j'ai besoin que ces gens-là
puissent recevoir un support financier
pour pas les amener dans une
vulnérabilité totale en même temps que
je continue à garder leur dossier actif
pour des traitements
pour l'instant il n'y a pas de
traitement pour guérir la covid longue
et l'espoir pour Valérie Mary
s'amenuisent après
tant qu'il est probable que cette
personne là se soit son état permanent
il écrit le ok mon médecin que que ma
situation va être permanente aussi à des
améliorations ça va être vraiment minime
si jamais suffisant pour pouvoir
retourner travailler là je suis outré
puis vraiment là je suis fâché
étendu sur son divan car oui en amigan
gère son groupe covidland Québec qui
compte 2500 membres j'ai des personnes
qui qui ont de tout vendre qui ont du
déménager chez leurs parents à 50 ans
les rendre je les ai payées
on empêche quand on travaille
je demande pas la charité
j'ai besoin d'aide
présentement
pour vivre
retraite Québec n'a pas voulu nous
accorder une entrevue on nous a écrit
que parmi les personnes qui souffrent de
covidland la grande majorité des
demandes a été acceptée mais on a refusé
de nous fournir les chiffres
quelques-unes heureusement ont été
acceptés mais ça pas été facile ça a été
beaucoup de travail souvent en révision
et avec peu de compréhension de la part
de retraite Québec
nous aurions voulu questionner le
ministre responsable Eric Girard sur la
rigidité de retraite Québec mais il a
refusé je me dis même moi à 37 ans
si j'attrape la covid la semaine
prochaine puis que je suis un des codes
de covid de langues j'ai malheureusement
très peu confiance que le système va
être en capacité de me supporter
une révision de la décision de retraite
Québec mais elle essuie un deuxième
refus le médecin évaluateur ne retient
aucun diagnostic de maladies physiques
ou organiques expliquant ces symp tômes
il précise qu'une évaluation en
psychiatrie apparaît indiquée j'ai un
rapport de ma psychologue qui dit que
tout va bien que dans le fond oui je
peux faire avoir l'anxiété par rapport à
mes symptômes parce que c'est très
limitatif mais il y a rien qui il y a
rien d'autre qui pourrait expliquer le
qu'est-ce que j'ai difficile à accepter
pour son père qu'il a soutient depuis le
début après tous les examens ça doit
être
après on fait quoi
c'est très très difficile
Nancy perron elle doit recommencer tout
le processus à cause de ces troubles
cognitifs elle a manqué la date limite
pour une révision
après plus d'un an d'absence elle
retourne saluer ses collègues au garage
où elle a travaillé pendant plusieurs
années
[Musique]
madame Perron a eu besoin d'une bonne
semaine pour se remettre de notre
tournage c'est ça le malaise posté fort
quand à Madame Meury elle conteste la
décision de retraite Québec devant le
Tribunal administratif du Québec il y a
9 à 12 mois d'attente avant l'Aude
audience